foreign
let's go to Kelly in Somerville what's
up Kelly
hi Dr John how are you
I'm fantastic how are you dude that's so
much better than I am I you just made me
go from to pretty good
oh God glad I could help that you're
fantastic is bringing us all up Kelly I
was fantastic earlier Kelly has this way
of dragging everybody down but not
really that's not true that's not true
it's super true Kelly it's super true
hey I'm so glad that you called what's
up
me too so I'm trying to figure out
what's going on with my 11 year old son
and food he has some very weird
behaviors
um he makes grunting noises he blinks
rapidly like almost like facial ticks he
becomes fixated on food I'm always
asking what the next meal is and when is
it he gets upset when I say no to eating
extra desserts um
I'm wondering if it's food scarcity
issues and I'm trying to understand
how to walk him through this without
shaming him I'm not sure what the best
way like to point out the noise to him
or is that going to make him
self-conscious so I'm just trying to get
clarity on what is really the root of
his issues with food and how to walk it
out with him oh man thank you so you
mentioned
um
might be food scarcity related tell me
more about that is there something has
passed yes my ex-husband uh put us
through financial issues constantly and
there were often times when we had a
negative uh balance in our account and I
couldn't buy food I had no food and so
he remembers a specific incident when
all I had was a potato and some cereal
um to give him and he brought that up a
couple weeks ago and said I thought you
were just too lazy to go to the grocery
store he was around five uh when that
happened but he remembers it quite
vividly so I'm like wondering is that
what this is about is there something
else going on and what do I do yeah
so
there could be a bunch of stuff here
um I'm gonna take a stab at it and I'm
gonna open this up to any therapist who
listened to the show and I hear from you
a lot a lot of you
um I'd love for your thoughts too
um here's my here's my guess just
listening just talking with you for a
couple of minutes okay Kelly
um well before I give you my guess let
me ask one more question was there any
abuse inside the home
they call it abuse my husband yelled a
lot he would throw high chairs when he
would get angry or whatever was around
him he never physically touched me or
the kids but he had a lot of anger
issues okay how old's your little one
uh
my youngest is six
my one I'm talking about is 11. oh yeah
you told me that you told me that 11.
okay
Okay so
let me say that there's several things
here there's the grunting there's the
ticks there which which is often a
body's way of just dealing with stress
or with anxiety right and so I don't
overthink that
um
that you I use that as a symbol as a
signal to me okay okay of a greater
internal distress
um so you have the yelling you've got
the food insecurity your son's got these
I'm gonna call them stories not Memories
um because he's now creating a new
Narrative of what happened inside of
what actually happened
and using that to reinforce his see what
I'm saying so it takes on a life of its
own to where his body is remembering
these stories less that they're a
play-by-play and in a couple years he'll
tell you another story and you'll think
I'm crazy I was there I know that didn't
happen and he will remember it as Vivid
right so it's about story right okay um
our bodies are our minds are story
making machines and they do that on the
back end of how we feel right so we have
these feelings in our bodies make
stories and
I think his body is responding to this
again I'm just throwing this out there
um I think his body is responding to a
life of Chaos
okay a life of
um not safe I'm not safe I'm not safe
and let's just take him at his word dad
was throwing furniture around
yeah Dad was probably radioactive even
when he wasn't throwing things around
and
um
somehow that narrative got transferred
over to you which is you're just too
lazy to even get me food
right
um or more importantly and this is where
I'm going to say this out loud guilt is
okay shame is not okay here don't don't
take this on
but it's often uh it's not uncommon for
a kid to ask why didn't you get me out
of there
or why did this go on for so long and
they don't understand economics they
don't understand just understand safety
and they look to you and say that was
that's your one job right and so
and that now you have 11 year old and
you put on top of that there were
Knights y'all went hungry there were not
so he has become fixated he has become
compulsive when it comes to food
right so our tendency is to pathologize
the food we're going to count calories
we're going to say
um only this you need some more protein
in that meal you need some more I want
to try a different approach okay now I'm
gonna say this for a third time and I
won't say it again all you therapists
out there if you're listening this going
no you let me know right in and
um we will I'll make the I'll say hey I
was wrong on this and
um we'll we'll change it on the show but
here's what I want you to do I want you
to change his context to his
relationship to you
and to the entire food ecosystem here's
what that means okay
take him shopping with you and give him
five things to pick out
okay let him be a part of that process
and by taking him to the store he's
gonna see how much food there actually
is out there
and that he has what we're giving him is
positive memories of an interaction with
an adult who's safe now
and with food
and we're also giving him teeny tiny
bits of controlled autonomy you have
choice
okay okay let him cook with you which I
know is the worst all right but he loves
to cook he loves it awesome buy him a
couple of cookbooks not internet recipes
buy them a couple of cookbooks or let
him pick out a couple of cookbooks what
are you interested in and read them with
him lay on his bed with him and flip
through the pages and look at him we
call him like uh it's like food
pornography or it's just like these
glossy beautiful stunning photos of food
that is not real but it just looks so
good
um if lay on his bed with him there help
let him help you organize the fridge
like okay just sit down okay where do
you think the milk should go where do
you think the egg should go I want you
to help me with this we're gonna model
healthy eating so it may be that we're
gonna get sweets out of the house and
you say things like not Twinkies make
you fat or chips make it you say things
like when I eat chips I don't feel good
my thinking gets cloudy
um I just don't my tummy doesn't feel
good and he might say I think they're
great and be like oh they taste so good
but I feel better when I and then you've
got to model it
okay
um so we're gonna focus on on mood and
performance not on body composition see
what I'm saying I don't ever want him to
feel like he's broken
um and then I'm gonna do this I'm gonna
send you the questions for humans cards
with the kids and here's why I want you
guys to slow down at family meals and if
you're not having family meals
that's all gotta change you guys okay
good you got to start doing that but I
want y'all to slow down so maybe it's as
a family we take one bite and then we
put our Fork down and then we're going
to answer one card and that is we're
just gonna learn we're gonna learn how
to slow down all of this is creating an
ecosystem of safety
and this is my sideways way of getting
you
to slow down and be highly intentional
and not being filled with guilt and
shame
because you are right
yeah oh yeah yes okay so I want you to
take these tools as an entry point into
a brand new relationship with your 11
year old
okay and
this is the hardest part
um
he knows that part of him is his dad too
right and that's going to haunt him
so he needs to know extra that he is
loved and that he's got value and that
he's smart and he's capable and all of
these things are a way to change the
entire environment around food
okay okay
um I also know the Lion's Share of This
falls on you and you probably don't have
a lot of free time you probably don't
have a lot of free extra money laying
around and I understand that this burden
disproportionately is something you got
to carry or if you heard me say
everything
you called ask how do I help him
um have a better relationship with food
and just stop being so anxious and my
answer was you have to change your
behaviors see what I'm saying sure
because he's just a kid absorbing that
home
um ticks quite honestly unless they are
um they keep him from having normal
functioning like he is chirping really
loud or he's grunting to the point that
people in the restaurant are turning to
look
um I would give that a season 60 days 90
days working on these other things and
see if that doesn't begin to
begin to heal itself if it doesn't then
it's time to go you could talk to
somebody so how does that help worried
about it sounds amazing okay I'm more
worried about like middle school and
kids making fun of him absolutely yes
yes and it's okay
to say not at the table
okay I don't even think he knows he's
doing it yes and it may just be parental
awareness hey you're grunting at the
table
what do you mean I'm grunting you're
making this noise
and it might just be somebody pointing
it out to him in love and you can do it
with a smile on your face in a way that
he knows it's not I don't love you less
just stop doing that okay you know what
I mean okay
um and here's another thing it's okay to
say no
he needs to hear you say no and have
healthy boundaries so if he says I need
ice cream and you say we're not having
ice cream tonight
um I'm the I'm the mom and we're not
having ice cream tonight we'll have ice
cream once a week on a special night if
fill in the blank happens
um and he gets mad at those temper
tantrums upset that's okay
he does when I he wanted two popsicles
and I said no and he got really angry
that's right
um that's okay that doesn't mean you did
something wrong and he has to
his anger's okay he's allowed to get
angry he's allowed to have his feelings
but he can choose to not have any more
popsicles for the rest of the week if he
if he says ugly things
right that's a choice he's making not
you're not punishing him with food
you're saying hey if you choose to yell
and scream and say something ugly or
throw something like like her like his
dad was doing he learned this by the way
um you're choosing not to have popsicles
don't do that because I love giving you
popsicles one of my favorite things
don't make that choice and then he's
gonna see yeah hold my beer I'll see if
she's really telling me the truth and
then you gotta decide are you actually
gonna do that or not is that fair right
yes absolutely I think that you can
transform this entire relationship
okay I may be way out to lunch and I'm
okay with being wrong on this if I this
was in my house this is right where I
would start
okay and by the way I'm a kid that grew
up with a lot of ticks
really yes a lot of them I was an
anxious kid and I was also an exhausted
kid
and so I blinked a lot I would grind my
teeth a lot I would pick my fingers a
lot like I did a lot I had a lot of
little ticks my friends used to make fun
of me I used to pop my neck a little bit
like I had all kind of weird stuff and
my buddies used to make fun of me about
all the time which by the way that was
their job they're just being kids
um but uh
I as an adult I've been able to track it
back almost directly to a lack of sleep
um and when I just get off the rails
with what I'm eating and I don't move my
body then man I start blinking again
real hard and I start cracking my neck
again all the things come back from when
I was a kid
um but it's it's not the tick itself
it's just a
it's it to me it's just an alarm system
okay saying you probably need to get
some rest dude you're starting to you're
starting to starting to I caught my
clicks I'm just trying to click a lot
again
um and it's pretty rare that happens
these days but it does happen
wow well thank you I is that cool very
helpful yes this is amazing and you are
the greatest mental health podcast yes I
knew it if you say it long enough okay
hey um but hear me say I'm a hundred
percent open to being wrong on this
um I would love it if you really gave
this a go for 30 days and you holler
back at me
back on the show and you can say I did
this and this and this and you're an
idiot this did not work or this did and
this didn't and here's why it may not be
um food for some parents it may be
clothes it may be I don't like these
these shoes feel weird on my feet it may
be any number of things that become a
moment of focus and control for a kid
because that's all they can control in
the world is this tiny little thing and
they're not doing it like to be mean
that's just their bodies have wrapped
themselves up in this one decision
because everything else in their life is
chaos and so if this works man that we
could be onto something is that cool
yeah yes thank you so much your little
one's really lucky to have you
are we done with the shame
yes promise
promise so dumb it's not that easy I
know but we're done right we're done yes
awesome you are the best Kelly let me
know how that goes and I look forward to
hearing from you